everybody we cannot stop talking about
this okay
am i an Instagram comment stalker a
little bit and this raised a question
for me so we had to look into it the
Internet is going crazy over a possible
new couple they have been flirting on
Instagram catching fans eyes including
my own with comments on each other's
posts so are Halsey and John Mayer
hooking up dating question mark did she
finally move on from gez finally
question mark is it too soon to say
Joel's Lea this is ithi investigates
let's look at the evidence everybody on
October 25th
halsy posting this photo with the
caption 38 degrees Fahrenheit well John
heats things up and responds with that's
two hundred and seventy six thousand
four hundred eighty three kelvins for
you and then thermal that's okay well
Monday then Halsey posts this pic
promoting her new YSL lipstick and
singer John Muir commenting with a funny
little caption it says my billing
address doesn't match the one with my
credit card I've never had this problem
before can you text me thanks well are
they texting Hosey replied with wrote
you a song with the help hotline number
in the chorus sending mp3 now mmm-hmm
then Tuesday were taking you through the
timeline Halsey does a 7:00 a.m. we'll
call it a carpool karaoke sash with John
you can see them there they took to
Instagram singing together facetiming
moon taking their friendship or maybe
more to another level we don't know who
wakes up this early for just a friend I
wake up this early to do this show but I
wouldn't do it for a man and we
continued to and we'll call it may be
stalking guys we look back to December
30th 2017 and look at this Oh photo
proof John Marin Halsey together looking
happy his arm around her now again she
did date G easy on and off and Halsey
maybe putting the rumors to rest mmm
here's what she tweeted yesterday quote
I just had a groundbreaking idea what if
we let female artists have friends
without assuming they're sleeping
together well I don't know Halsey I have
to say we kind of love it because we're
shipping the two of you imagine the
songs out of a Halsey John Mayer
relationship everybody what do you think
tweet us and let us know at ET Now
hashtag ET live our Halsey and John
Mayer dating
that was et investigates
[Music]
[Applause]